ربك الا تعبدون
الا اياه افراد العائله بعضهم لبعض
ويؤخركم الى اجل مسمى جهد سنوات استطاعوا
خلالها حفظ القران الكريم كاملا
[موسيقى]
عمرو احد اصغر الحفاظ في غزه بات مستعدا
بعد رحله طويله
الى ان وصلنا الى هذا اليوم انه نصفه
بالقوان على جلسه واحده في مشروع صفه
الحفاظ انا واخوتي باذن الله عز وجل
وظلالهم بالغدو والاصال جلسه واحده تكفي
شعار مشروع صفوه الحفاظ
جلسه تمتد من صلاه الفجر وحتى صلاه المغرب
حتى اذا حضر احدهم
مئات الحفاظ القران غيبا هذا المشروع
شجعنا فيه غير الحفاظ على اتمام حفظهم
لكتاب الله شجعنا الحفاظ القدامى على
مراجعه محفوظهم كان عندنا 581 اليوم نحن
نرى ثلاث اضعاف في العدد نريد من هذا
المشروع ان يكون حاله مجتمعيه ان يصبح
يوما وطنيا
ونيوتهم ابواب شرائح وفئات عمريه مختلفه
تشارك في هذا العمل سعيا للاجر واظهار
صوره مختلفه عن غزه المحاصره كان العدد في
النسخه الاولى 5
80 اليوم 14
00 والمهندس والمدرس ورجل الشرطه وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه كلهم بفضل الله عز وجل
يشاركون اليوم ويسبح الرعد بحمده امتلات
مساجد غزه بالحفاظ وتجمع صفوه حفظه كتاب
الله
ليرتلوا القران ترتيلا مشروع صفوه الحفاظ
يعتبر المشروع القراني
الاضغ عن سنويا في غزه ويسعى القائمون
عليه لتخريج اجيال حافظه لكتاب الله
وتقديم نموذج فريد من غزه الى العالم هشام
زقوط الجزيره غزه فلسطين